hey everybody and welcome back to
qawalli Beach last week oh my god well
you know we are managing this this this
big corporation with different parks
across the world sometimes you mess up
one name with you one you know it
happens we have different resorts all
across the world that's just yeah sylph
has the technical resort definitely fine
Oh God so anyway welcome welcome back to
koala Zoo last week Mike had to take it
over from me because I had a bunch of
school responsibilities that I had to
take care of so thank you very much Mike
oh you're very welcome
yeah that's it's honestly it was really
great actually I highly recommend
everyone everybody to check it out if
you haven't yet because it was a really
cool episode where he created the
Flamingo habitat right in front of the
building that I'm working on right now
so it gives a pretty good context as to
what that is like and if you've already
seen it go watch it back before this
video to refresh your mind or something
and but could be useful you never know
and as always we have Rudy here as well
of course yes god it's a bit strange to
like introduce you guys after you've
already introduced yourself anyway in
this episode I'll be trying to work on
this building here which finishes the
Flamingo habitat that Mike worked on in
the last episode and I'll also be doing
some stuff alongside the main Boulevard
going through the zoo which originally I
didn't really dare to tackle but I'll be
making one little scene there but that's
something we'll get to later on I mean
the Boulevard has been your project if
anybody's going to tackle it it's gonna
be you exactly oh well you knew you want
to tackle that Mike but just when
silver's finished
just the gardening part yeah yeah yeah
yeah exactly I know your parasitic ways
I'll try to like build a bunch of stuff
and you can swoop in with some gardening
I'm still dying over the text you have
the most amazing quotes Rudy you just do
I guess yeah it's like a blender of
English and it's just amazing that it's
a blender of English not another
language I mean this is really cool
though when I first saw this I'm like oh
yeah that's that's amazing that totally
fits oh yeah it does what the quotes
anymore right okay never mind no I guess
not if I can give a bit of backstory
about this building as always I I have
to do my bit of architectural
exploration before I build I just love
to procrastinate on Wikipedia and Google
Images until the end of time and just
kind of have to force myself to start
building at some point too but what I
tried to do is there's this really
beautiful sort of modern aesthetic to
this whole area and I wanted to keep
that but at the same time I wanted to
incorporate some very local touches as
well so this building is inspired by
well Indonesian temples and I'm gonna
have to look up in the background which
one's exactly because I actually didn't
save any of the exact inspirations but
there are these temples with a really
difficult name that I don't know by
hearts which have very pointy curvy
spires on the size of their roofs mm-hmm
and that's the general shape that this
building was inspired by as well as a
modern mosque somewhere in Indonesia
which also takes some inspirations from
these roof shapes so it's very much
using traditional shapes but putting
them in a different context
and also using different materials
because obviously the material use here
is quite contemporary so it's really
actually quite a basic shape but then
there's the sort of decorative big spire
in front which doesn't really serve any
architectural purpose but it's really
just there to make the building a bit
more interesting and yeah make it fit
into the into the scene of the Flamingo
habitat in front of it a bit more yeah
Bravo it's really really dynamic and
really cool and it's it's that mixture
of styles that because I was I was way
okay with just having that kind of
typical Polynesian look and then you're
like now we're not doing that yeah
forgive my mind messing up the intro but
at the end of the day I think one of one
of our first sort of goals here is to
not make it look like another quality
Beach and really go into a different
direction and while retaining the the
sort of same biome yeah so I think yeah
sorry you know I think we can sort of
keep doing that here I love it I love it
I remember when we first brainstormed
about the the different architectural
styles wanted to go for and we're
throwing in like you know images and
stuff and over the past couple episodes
we we started to establish this more and
more but I love this touch of of you
bringing back now the bit more
traditional Polynesian styles especially
with the roofs and stuff which I think
blends in a lot more with the entrance
now but also it kind of moves to what
what Mike did and also I try to do a bit
more with the Education Center and you
know these kind of things I love how
this isn't a really living thing you
know you can really tell that there were
different timeframes when the buildings
were made and they took inspiration from
the different things and I really love
how this comes out now and I think now
we're at this point where we talked
about early on in the last episode that
how our building styles are differing so
much from each other but now this is
really what self can can bring up again
just this wonderful architectural blend
of styles and still make it look really
cool as if it really was meant to be
that way and I really think that was
needed again and I just love it
I can
tell them really happy about this
building sitting exactly where it sits
it's really in that little next my
catcher I guess you know just avoided
another word here yeah thanks and I
think it also makes sense in this sort
of layout of a zoo
of course it's really different from
koala Beach in a sense that everything
will be made over different periods and
very much organically and also very much
depending on whichever habitat its
related to so I think going for a large
variety of different architectural
styles which is to fit the nature of a
zoo much more as well yeah I mean this
building looks like it is in one of
those architecture text books of like oh
this is a perfect example of blank
design or something like that it's just
so it almost it feels a little I keep
coming back to about 70s for this kind
of the style where they took traditional
religious kind of shapes and stuff like
that and they put them in modern
materials which allowed them to do
really cool like stretched out big
plaster things and that's kind of what
it feels like to me I don't know if that
was your inspiration or era yeah I
actually for me it's been tough I
actually wouldn't know exactly what kind
of era or style to put this building in
exactly mm-hmm
it's definitely regionalism you know
there's this general philosophy of
taking modern technology and modern
contemporary building styles I should
say contemporary in the context of
architecture and taking local influences
and embedding that in that but yeah I
don't know exactly what kind of style it
would be yet I think personally I'm
feeling something 90s maybe early zeroes
something like that but it could
definitely be from the seventies as well
it feels like churches of that era the
big white spire and stuff like that and
the very oh yeah right
I think that's you mean like those those
sub urban churches we find not the u.s.
a little bit yeah that's such a like an
interesting style architecture I've
always found because it's they're always
very modern churches obviously these
suburbs are all from the 50s 60s 70s 80s
mhm and the US suburb churches have such
a typical style to them I can definitely
see the resemblance I think it really
fits to this comparison but I'm a little
bit like also split on that it could be
like really back to the 70s but I'm also
with yourself because I remember that at
the moment at least I see even today
buildings changed back a little bit into
this style it almost feels like very
modern to me because they try to re
embrace this more classical into the
very modern buildings I mean surely it
would then use a bit more even more
modern materials like I don't know
aluminum or I don't know even metal
and it surely is not it's surely plaster
so I don't know but I really love this
unique style and I love how this really
catches the attention in that area in
particular but not too much you know
it's not stealing too much attention
from the habitat on the earth the
exhibition hall you did Mike so I'm
quite impressed by how it fits in
already it just feels right I think it's
not even too important which which time
it is but it feels right it feels
fitting I think it's really cool well
that's gonna be the challenge that a lot
of people have kind of brought up like
okay so you've got Rudy's area you got
Mike's area got two ladies area you got
sales entrance how do you bring that
together well that's what a
collaboration is and that's what we're
aiming to figure out when we start
filling in the gaps you're gonna start
seeing these styles kind of homogenized
a little bit yeah yeah and I definitely
felt that with this as well because for
for how I feel personally I would never
be able to do the Flamingo habitat
itself and nearly as well the foliage
and rock work and that is just
next-level but then I feel like for me
it's it's it's better to like swoop in
and fill in that empty spot well Mike
goes on and does his gardening somewhere
else it's really these sort of
things where you can complement each
other and I must say it's more it's like
really it's really also embracing the
way how an actual Zoo is planned as well
you don't have that one architect
planning out the zoo I actually very
seldom you know might be that there are
some examples we have a fully plan now
to do but even then like this would only
be correct for the beginning but later
on it definitely would be someone else
taking over changing bits and pieces and
you know so at the end of the day it's
how a real zoo would work as well you
have like a different area and then you
have an architect planning on that area
and then another one has to work off of
what they are the one started you know
yep the way this is coming together as
almost like there was a zoo here before
or there there was at least a somewhat
of a zoo like around the temple ruins or
something like that and then they
decided we can turn this into a resort
so now it's a zoo hybrid kind of resort
with different modern architectural
styles and a little bit more of a push
for resort amenities and stuff like that
yep mm-hmm is the way that I'm seeing
how this is evolving yeah I could
definitely see that yeah there's also
about to say even one person can have
totally different styles like here I'm
completely shifting from the last
building into something which also tries
to blend a traditional styles with
something that is from the other side of
the world in this case this was mainly
inspired by the old town of Jakarta and
that's generally well I've been sending
so many pictures of the old town jakarta
into our own little disco group so they
have an old town which is like really
the old colonial area of the city built
by the Dutch and it features a lot of
Dutch colonial architecture with the
canal in the middle of it and even a
Dutch bridge as well and I thought this
was something really interesting and
just generally a lot of architecture
that I was really inspired by and wanted
to try out also because for some reason
I have never really done much Dutch
architecture and this is this is really
close to that
it was really fun to try out I really
loved also how much this is working as a
Main Street ish you know you say you
work on the basic Main Street area but I
love how this I don't know why it really
reminds me so much of a Main Street but
I think these Dutch buildings have the
big advantage of having the the
wonderful big facade that meal plan
lends away the background a lot which is
the style you know if I remember for
example Amsterdam and the canals and
stuff you always have this like huge sad
sparking off what's behind so you really
get that immersed feeling of being in
the center of that like a little town
area you know and I think this is
exactly how a Main Street also works you
have this this one facade with a lot of
detail and with a lot of styles and then
that what's what in the back is not as
important you know and that's
yeah I'm really thinking that would work
perfectly fine for the Main Street I
like the idea of almost lost Vegas
sameness and thinking if this was
actually if this was an addition to when
they put the the hotel in the resort in
this is like the shopping promenade and
so you have this sort of traditional
architecture but it's done it's done in
a way that is almost like a theme park
where it's it's not it didn't exist
before it's it's referencing something
else you know in the culture or
something like that and then you also
have the capitalist court culture
attached to it where people are you know
going and eating and buying things and
stuff like that yeah yeah actually I
wanted to keep it a very open to
interpretation so I didn't specifically
choose for either this being commercial
and sort of facade ism or this this
being real original Dutch colonial
buildings I think it could really be
both and it's like what Rudy said even
traditionally these buildings have very
front focused and they'll have a lot of
detail and decoration on the front and
then on the sides it's it's much
different and much more simple so even
with what I've been building here
recently I think you can still go two
ways you know this could either be they
could even be moved buildings you know
from a different location brought over
here and reconstructed I don't know
there's it's always interesting to try
and come up with this story to the
whatever you're building in planets ooh
so that's something to maybe work out
later but for now I just thought yeah
this would be a really cool sort of main
street like Boulevard section and
generally very much inspired by the
Jakarta whole town but at the same time
none of the buildings specifically are
based on buildings in the Jakarta old
town that was really sort of an
interesting way that I ended up
approaching this because these buildings
are generally religious inspired by
actual buildings in the Netherlands but
then I'm trying to give them the spin
that the colonial Dutch architecture
seems to have so of course the textures
are very different instead of dark
bricks we're using white plaster mmm
because that makes the buildings a lot
more cool of course the the roof colors
are a bit different that very orangey
color that you tend to see a lot of in
Indonesia and what's also a bit
different is the way they interact with
the streets most Dutch buildings in the
Netherlands are really just a flat
facade but I found a lot of buildings in
colonial areas not just in Indonesia but
also in Malaysia for instance where they
have these overhanging eaves or some
kind of arched hallway in front of the
building which I guess provides some
shade and makes for a better way of
interacting with the street in in a much
warmer climate and so I did try to
incorporate some of this into it as well
nice which is also very very good in
terms of weather because it's also very
rainy over there at times and so if we
turn that into like a shopping for sir
you know promenade or whatever it could
actually act also has a little bit of a
shelter for rain once there is this very
heavy rain pouring down you can at least
still go on and move from one building
to the other I know my crazy brain
though is already thinking about what if
we put a cover over the whole thing like
they're doing in Asia I was just about
to say have you seen I was this the the
main street in Universal in Osaka in
Japan and it's also the main street in
Disneyland Tokyo I think has the cover
oh yeah yeah yeah and that was added
behind it was that it was edit after the
fact right
I think they built the Main Street first
like the original Main Street and then
just over it it's kind of crazy yeah I'm
not sure but it's definitely very unique
amazing is how you pull these textures
together that's like oh that's just
that's just clearly Chinese and then as
you go further it's like oh well that's
actually getting a little bit less
Chinese it's really cool right and I
guess I I was feeling the that I was
actually looking for some brackets to
use for these decorations for a while
there's not a lot that you can use here
so this was honestly one of my best
options for now at the same time though
I I wasn't really too afraid to use the
Chinese pieces because at the end of the
day there is actually a huge Chinese
population in Indonesia and you can
definitely find my Chinese influences
there so even that I think could work
out all right in the end just one more
addition to the to the Asian pieces like
I think they're mainly inspired by by
Chinese but in the game they're also
called and East Asia definitely make
thesis and not specifically yeah like
you know I mean it is clearly Chinese
but it's it's still called
East Asia and I guess like that did a
good job on making it not to spot on
Chinese why this might be also a reason
why we can use them a bit more versatile
but yeah I still think there could be
more you know there's so much more to
the East Asian style that could be in
there so I really hope that there is a
chance of getting a bit more specific
for example Japanese sort of theming
yeah that's just amazing the just the
more you layer and the more that you use
these Dutch tenets of architecture that
you can take these these wild textures
and put them together and it functions
yeah I think I I ended up doing a bit of
experimentation before I started working
on this just to see which pieces you
know could work
which part of the building the most
important thing that I ended up focusing
on a lot was the Gables
because when it comes to Dutch
architecture it's it's all about the the
facades upfront and that they have these
typical Gables that you find in many
Dutch buildings so for instance if you
go from right to left on the buildings
here on the right you have what they
call a clock gable which is curved on
the sides and then rounded up top with
just one texture for the whole thing and
then the middle one is what's often
called a staircase which is where you
have these little steps very common
everywhere in the Netherlands and for
this one I'm trying to go for something
that's a bit like your neck Gable well
that's literally translated from that I
don't know if there's a proper English
term for it it didn't work out that well
but I think at the end of the day for
for a dormer jutting out on the front it
is really that one element which tells
you that okay this isn't just any
European architecture but specifically
Dutch because this is really where I
think Dutch architecture even the
colonial one really separates itself
from other European styles we're getting
a canal - I'm not sure we getting a
canal oh you know what yeah actually
yeah I wasn't sure for a while if I
wanted to but at the end of the day yeah
I figured I have to do it I also
couldn't really come up with a better
way to make the Boulevard in the middle
of the park so yeah here's the canal so
I'm gonna try to work on that for a bit
right now as well plus it actually
connects to the lake of the flamingos as
well so you can we can built this whole
sort of water ecosystem where everything
is a bit interconnected because the
river connecting on the other side of
the flamingo's is of course also has
this little business and you're gonna
bet that there's gonna be some trash
wherever there's people so let's expect
it now yeah every episode just a little
bit more true I think she couldn't have
to add
later because I forgot to add some trash
in this this canal but there will
undoubtedly be some I really love how
this is coming together like I I do love
the area where you built in that really
sets up a new challenge now for next
fall ad to come up I think she's first
of all going to finish working on her
exhibit for the gharial but I think
later on it will be very interesting to
to blend in this first area because we I
think we came to a point where our areas
are close enough to each other to think
about the way how they are connected at
least so I'm gonna be very exciting to
see how this works out okay I think I
know a little bit okay that's very good
because I did leave some areas open for
you to like pick apart
I just realized really that we didn't
even say why ladies not here I will be
honest maybe you can maybe you can add
audio video yeah well just well it will
just add a little I'll just take a clip
of one of lady's videos where just where
she just goes hi guys for all of the
audience out there lady currently has a
flu so I hope she gets better soon I
swear man we just don't have that junk
[Music]
that's kind of counterintuitive but
maybe it is
yeah I got some protesters here because
of the box when he goes oh wow this is a
lot closer to the Flamingo habitat
minute yeah interesting yeah I was
looking at that like there's no space
for this Boulevard to happen so maybe a
little bit of foliage from the Flamingo
habitat that's gonna have to be moved
maybe even opened so you can have
another over here just some random ideas
always so that the staff members I even
more like well now my cover has to be
cantilever okay has to support the
weight on the other side of the building
oh that's gonna be the Dutch bridge over
here not right yeah yeah yeah
this is a the typical Dutch bridge that
you see in a lot of places this one in
particular was mostly modeled after the
marketer hang bridge in Amsterdam which
is one of the iconic bridges in
Amsterdam but not entirely it's it's a
bit of a mix of things and there's even
one of these bridges in Jakarta which is
really cool
however the Jakarta one is brown and I I
do think the earth looks better so yeah
it does any better with the area I think
is the first real usage of chain-link
[Laughter]
yeah it's actually really fun to build
this thing I remember a long time ago
actually tried building a Dutch city and
what Costa country and a friend of mine
built one of these bridges and Sketchup
imported it into the game and since then
I've always wanted to make one of these
and what so now what six years later or
something like that and I'm finally
building one of these bridges so Brian
if you're seeing this the thanks for for
all the help you've given me these years
this you've inspired me to finally
tackle my own bridge it's really fun
actually
I mean that's like quite some time oh
wow yeah I'm really I'm really I like I
really like the design of the original
it's like you're adding so much detail
but it makes it look really really great
because it adds so much weight to the
little rounded corners there it's just a
nice touch to you also how yeah you did
the path thing that's so clever it might
be one of the first things just
obviously little it's funny because
actually I wasn't always sure if I was
gonna do it like this if I was gonna
film the bridge like this but then when
I tried connecting the paths it
automatically made this okay like this
ugly little bit in the middle and then I
thought to myself wait if you're gonna
do that anyway I might as well see if I
can it's the game with its awkward path
mechanism is featuring some creativity
drive for you that's good awesome
yep I mean at the end of the day
creativity does come from limitations as
well so true Dutchman here he's making
it yeah
he's controlling the water yeah I myself
actually realized also that we have a
bit of a water level difference here
some different heights and I wasn't sure
what to do with that big last fence but
I own the whole thing maybe Mike you
want to go back at some point and change
some things that's totally fine by me
that's at the end of the day I I think
your job is to take our stuff and just
improve and add to it and that's it
looks good to me
but I added a small pumping station oh
that's really nice all right
yeah this pumping station is actually
also just modeled after the one that's
often used in the Netherlands - well
basically keep the country thank you
from being a plane for now now until the
sea level rises even more
so yeah that's that's it for the time
lapse but I would like to show off the
park a little bit in real time as well
if that's okay about you guys yeah go
ahead em okay so we're back and we're
gonna see if a little theory is because
the yeah the spire is such a vertical
elements in what is otherwise very
horizontal sending just everything about
it the rock work the path here the the
roof structure of the building except
for this big spire even the way the sort
of valley in to that it's very cool yep
I love that it follows almost the tilted
around the shape of the roof so that you
know the foliage gets higher up to the
sides following the the roundish line
Alta it gives you this dis valley
weather when the building is in my job
was honestly quite easy because just the
way that all of the foliage around here
frames this spot it's just absolute so
so from this part you can see it in the
distance as well and the same goes for
the little path over the bridge here
you've got it peeking through the bamboo
trees there
I just love let me come up with
guidelines finally I would be mad at you
if in your videos the work that sight
line I'm not gonna say the other term
although it is a grill use the term
weenies it is it is definitely maybe
shouldn't use the terminology in zoos
although yeah it can definitely work for
zoos to do I mean the concept is also
like really old already like all these
ancient and towns I've had this
naturally engine to make you know to
have easy for traders to know where to
go so it's basically very very old
concept so yeah but I think it's it's
really cool but wouldn't colonial people
that anyways because I'm
like you know kind of sculpting over the
the stages into the area they just kind
of went to and made this down you know I
I mean I try to you know yeah just just
like some of the locals but yeah it's
it's just you know we do it for science
this is a beautiful shot you go yeah
yeah it is I mean it's interesting yeah
it's interesting because in real life
it's also you know obviously colonialism
has has left a bad taste in many
people's mouths but at the same time I
think there are a few things where it
sort of lets a cultural enrichment and
architecture is definitely something
where hate it or love it
it created sort of new styles and things
that are still appreciated so the old
town of Jakarta has a lot of heritage
buildings these these old Dutch colonial
buildings and just a week ago I think I
discovered that the the central canal
running through the area was renovated
and it looks very very nice and shiny
and well-maintained right so it's
actually it seems to be quite respected
and it's becoming more of a tourist
hotspot now too
so it is interesting so maybe don't put
litter in the canals it's the guest so I
guess you have to sort of see everything
in a bit of a nuance thing and sometimes
I don't know if colonialism is such a
difficult history to look back and I
know it seemed very disenchanted when I
was sort of touching upon this in the
first episode but I think I think you
just have to sometimes take a step back
and admit that you you know appreciate
that the sort of art or architecture of
its while recognizing that the real life
situation we were terrible and that
these colonial buildings were
built by a government which which
oppressed locals etc but why am I
getting so political in a place in terms
of history it's never really
rose-colored and as much as we'd like to
admit yeah this is just a snapshot of a
time a period in time in which there was
change in in the country right yep and
you know we're just fortunate that that
is a game yeah at the end of three and
and that's the thing that's the thing
which like from this Pandora's box of
I'm just drawing it's like really cool
mix of different cultures when it comes
to architecture I'll leave everything
else in the books for now at least oh
that's so fitting to to blue zoo leave
it all in boxes oh yeah yeah I'm not
gonna unbox that Pandora's box no matter
how many you know
[Laughter]
[Music]
that's funny yeah I always as a child
always was like fascinated by colonial
buildings in like a tropical or a
different a wild setting I think there's
sort of romanticism about it but then
you also as you grow up you start to
learn oh yeah it's not as it's not as
not as nice but here it's beautiful it's
just it's a thematic choice yeah we
didn't there's no nobody lives here and
whoa I just built a blue pin oh we're
not gonna do that
okay guys so that's what I'm actually
building okay yeah so I think I think
we've gone off topic enough it's time to
give this park to somebody who's gonna
do the next episode actually is it you
that's a good point yeah well if at all
I'll jump in but um I guess she will be
fine I guess yeah she's already
finishing up when she's watching the
video again so first we're forgetting
about her way to be so okay I'll link
the playlist in the top comment on the
video in any mystery of course you guys
channels in the description so whatever
the next episode is gonna be yeah you
guys as viewers are gonna have to be
able I find it somehow yeah
I'll leave you my my job is done do
whatever no I'll try my best
yeah collaboration but they quickly
start you know falling apart in terms of
how organization goes I suppose we
didn't expect a plague to roll through
and some food poisoning okay no I'm
sorry I didn't plan on that we don't go
back to there no but I'm also led
already to the hospital that I didn't
have a PC there like I thought it was
mandatory to have a streaming piscine I
am really rent a mill perhaps you've
heard of me you have cards no just drop
them off as like tips at restaurants
like here yeah we got off the rails
twice yeah yeah yeah we really need to
thanks you guys for watching thank you
Mike and Rudy for for being here with me
and yeah it's pretty great honestly and
yeah I hope to it's been fun yeah it's
been a little bit of an off topic video
sometimes things just go so random
podcast about colonialism and food
poisoning yeah I mean we are a bunch of
young white males we realistically need
to start a podcast at some point but
there was also another direction yeah we
did the conversation didn't go off the
rail I just landed on a whole different
rail and went from
all right I would show this because I
really have to start making food okay
okay all right yeah
that's all you still have to say right
yeah I already thanked the viewers for
watching I thank you guys for being here
yeah mmm